le débrief de yassine belattar 20 public
hier vous avez reçu il ya de moins que
50 minutes du coup hier on a une
nouvelle émission sur ces 8 après le 6 à
7 avec bernard le 8 à 9 avec yann moix
50 minutes c'est très long c'est la
durée d'une mi-temps de foot+ les arrêts
de jeu et en plus y avait même pas
benzema le problème c'est que yann moix
il est souvent dans l'ombre où il
regardé cette génération de médecins
l'enfant gâté qui ont oublié quand ils
ont commencé leurs études de médecine de
faire un peu de philosophie de réfléchir
ça donne en fait ce que j'appelle moi
des beaufs de la médecine
ce sont des gens voilà les saisons la
gym adulte et par ce mec ça suffit ça va
bien on a besoin à mon pote schématique
authier p2 voilà il est maxi cocotiers
p2 donc tu te calmes jan
c'est fou date dans la brousse comme ça
en plus sade et assure son entourage ont
gardé j'ai retrouvé le chat de yann moix
[Musique]
depuis hier une nouvelle expression est
entré dans la langue française le mois
que ce jeu qui veut dire parler de soi
sans s'arrêter pendant 20 minutes
d'ailleurs on la connaît aussi le grand
bleu parce que quand il parle il est
souvent en apnée d'ailleurs il a battu
le record hier regarder ça s'est joué en
finale la mort à laquelle on ne s'était
plus habituée depuis plus de cinquante
ou soixante ans soixante dix ans est
devenu tout d'un coup ils intolérable
insupportable c'est à dire que l'idée
même de mourir avait disparu de notre
horizon et on s'est habitué quasiment
fait d'elle on avait autour de nous des
gens qui mouraient n'en avait pas eu la
sensation qu'on pouvait à mourir nous à
tout moment comme on l'a vu pendant
virus même pendant les actes terroristes
on n'a pas ça et du coup on s'est
acclimaté dangereusement au fait que la
mort était illégale iny site illégitime
et anormales se rappelle tout d'un coup
de notre mortalité a fait un effet boom
dans la société humaine et tout d'un
coup on a trouvé inadmissible que les
vaccins n'arrive pas plus vite
inadmissible que les hôpitaux soient
pleins tout est devenu inadmissible mais
ce qu'on ne supporte plus cyril et c'est
pour ça qu'on est en désaccord parce que
francis lalanne il fait ce qu'il veut
moi je ne suis pas du tout dans ce
registre là voilà quelques enfants sont
là du après gêne parce que la phrase
durée de 12 minutes
il a battu le plongeur à part ça mon
cher bernard aujourd'hui c'est la
réouverture des terrasses la guerre
commence pour boire un mojito
voici donc un nouvel épisode de votre
documentaire de guerre babac alips 19
mai 2021
la france retient son souffle après des
mois de guerre bactériologique une
offensive géantes des milliers de
quartier se préparent toutes les
terrasses sont en passe d'être prise
d'assaut un seul mot d'ordre un vert et
contre tous du coup que va faire la dark
armée dont il être de courageux
travailleur est quand même allé bosser
ou vont-ils être tous des bernard
montiel
c'est ce que nous allons vous raconter
dans ce nouvel épisode 2
baca lips
nous sommes le premier jour du monde
d'après les cafetiers sortent
l'artillerie lourde
tables chaises parasols les fameux parra
qui ne sont pas sans rappeler ceux du
débarquement
certains construisent même des lofts à
même le trottoir
à l'instar des tranchées de la première
guerre mondiale la france se détend les
gens qui n'ont rien à faire de leurs
journées se pose en terrasse comme on
dit à paris
le virus est terrassé au qg de la dark
armée c'est le branle bas de combat ou
plutôt le branle rien le combat des
bureaux sont vides tout le bataillon des
chroniqueurs et en terrasse au lieu de
préparer l'émission du jour
le colonel morini bosc qui a toujours
peur d'attraper le qu'ovide mélange
l'alcool et les vaccins elle enchaîne
les whiskys pfizer et les vodkas zeneca
le sergent guillaume genton dit le
sergent ton est déjà en train
d'organiser des soirées avec des
influenceurs plus inquiétant toute la
journée on est sans nouvelles du
maréchal verdez l'état-major envoie des
troupes dans tout paris pour le trouver
c'est la fameuse bataille de verdun le
général baba lui est débordé car il doit
répondre à toutes les invitations de
boire un verre de ses anciens invités de
tpm p un médecin urgentiste un médecin
rassure east un médecin alarmiste un
médecin trapéziste va policiers un
pompier un avocat un patron de bar un
patron de boîte de nuit
un patron club échangiste un couple
échangiste un médecin échangiste un
candidat des anges un candidat des
marseillais un candidat à la
présidentielle est un chat alors
l'émission touche pas à mon poste
pourra-t-elle yeux aucun hellemmes ce
soir at on retrouvé gilles verdez c'est
ce que vous allez savoir
dans les minutes qui viennent
la retrouver
ça on l'a retrouvé
gilles verdez qui s'était caché dans une
chicha
[Applaudissements]